joe biden is not taking vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine lying down no siree
yesterday he got some staff member to
prop him up and in that brief spurt of
relative vigor and lucidity he promised
to rebuke putin push him away from
ukraine he sent a warning to the russian
leader
there is still time to avert the worst
case scenario that will bring untold
suffering to millions of people if they
move as suggested
the united states and our allies and
partners remain open to diplomacy if it
is serious
when all is said and done
we're going to judge russia by its
actions not its words
and whatever russia does next we're
ready to respond with unity
clarity and conviction
we'll probably have more to say about
this as
it moves on i'm hoping diplomacy is
still available thank you all very much
unity
clarity and conviction
joe biden one of the most divisive
presidents in american history a man who
accused mitt romney of trying to put
black people back in chains a man who
just recently called half of the country
neo-nazis
he is going to
unite the world
joe biden a man who has not spoken a
proper english sentence since the bush
administration doddering old joe biden
is going to
bring the world together through the
clarity of his soaring logic
and rhetoric joe biden
a man who has reversed every single one
of his most cherished beliefs the moment
that they became politically
inconvenient joe biden the physical
incarnation of an empty
suit
joe biden is going to lead the world on
the clarity of his convictions
if i were ukraine i would start rallying
the troops i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday comes from
m account who says i have no problem
drafting women into war so long as they
are the kind of whimson with maidenly
adam's apples winning these swim races i
agree those women can be drafted that
way we will have true equality and we
will still only have men
uh fighting our wars and being
slayed by the
forces of russia that are actually
aggressing because they actually have a
much more serious country unfortunately
than we do right now one of the reasons
that we don't have a terribly serious
country is because we don't really make
anything anymore and we we outsource all
the stuff that we need well one good way
to consume wonderful american products
good ranchers go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now do it right now you
are going to thank me later i love these
guys okay i am something of a meat
aficionado
all right i i eat red meat almost every
single day i know it's not going to be
good i'm probably going to get gout you
know any day now but i love it and i've
got very exacting standards good
ranchers has phenomenal meat it's by the
way it's not just red meat either i had
their chicken the other night grilled it
up the chicken is magnificent they've
got lots of different seasonings and
things
and then the beef is just wonderful the
steaks are great the hamburgers are
great
i've got a freezer full of this stuff
it's 100 american meat so not only is it
delicious but unlike that meat you're
getting in the grocery store this meat
is actually supporting american ranchers
okay and it's also supporting this show
so if you like this show it's it's not
uh it's not easy for advertisers always
to support conservative podcasts and
conservative causes so i really give
these guys a lot of credit they're
supporting good old-fashioned american
values and they have an amazing product
to boot head on over to goodranchers.com
knowles today
they've got a whole bunch of different
subscriptions you can get a whole bunch
of different boxes you can order one off
right now if you use code knowles you
can get 30 bucks off your box now is the
time go head over to goodranchers.com
knowles today you will thank me later
joe biden is the the last political hope
for peace on earth goodness gracious
you remember i talked about this
yesterday on the show vladimir putin
gave a speech a couple of days ago
in which he laid out the rationale for
war in ukraine the historical rationale
the political
ukraine situation in ukraine and the
security concerns for russia he may have
told some lies he may have made up some
history but he was clear he was forceful
he was persuasive because he's a
statesman with all of his wits about him
yesterday joe biden gave i guess sort of
kind of a speech and the part you just
heard that was probably the clearest
part of the speech the rest of it was
just hammering and wandering and nothing
particularly specific and nothing
persuasive at all
yesterday
the world heard clearly
the full extent of vladimir putin
twisted rewrite of history
going back more than a century as he
waxed eloquently
noting
that well i'm not going to go into it
but nothing in putin's length of remarks
indicate any interest in pursuing real
dialogue
yesterday vladimir and he's what did he
do he well it doesn't matter what he did
he uh but he's gonna do he's gonna and
we're gonna stop him because of our
unity clarity and conviction are you i
don't if i were vladimir putin i would
be champing at the bit to move not just
into those breakaway regions of ukraine
but all the way up to kiev
we pointed it out yesterday donald trump
is the only president of the last four
on whose watch vladimir putin didn't
invade a sovereign country
why is that
why is that i asked this question to
liberals and the best answer they could
muster is well they were they were
already getting everything they wanted
from trump
what were they getting what did they get
from trump
tougher sanctions than any of the other
presidents
land they didn't get any land they what
what did they get uh the pipeline that
the north stream two pipeline no
that was halted under trump what did
they get they ain't get anything i was
on c-span maybe a month or so ago and
some
lunatic left-wing caller
claimed that donald trump was trump's
puppet
i said how was
donald trump was trump's open donald
trump was vladimir putin's puppet i said
how is that the case what did he do and
the caller stammered and then hung up
you see there was no answer
so the left has nothing here the reason
is clear it's not i'm not you don't even
need to believe that donald trump is the
greatest statesman in the history of the
world to know this trump was strong and
unpredictable those are two things you
want to be in foreign policy vladimir
putin he wasn't 100 certain that if he
invaded ukraine that that trump would
send in the 101st airborne but he didn't
know he didn't know trump is kind of a
madman right trump is the guy who calls
little rocket man short and fat in korea
right trump is the guy who
calls off certain missile strikes and
then blows up some other places and you
just don't know so vladimir putin didn't
want to take the chance with biden he
knows nothing's going to happen
and so russia has authorized the use of
military force the russian duma has
unanimously authorized putin to use
military force in ukraine
putin has given the order the first
troops have already moved in they have
moved in you got to get you got to give
the guy credit he might be an evil
mastermind but you got to give him
credit he has sent in peacekeeping
forces
to the sovereign country that he's
invading he says hey listen we got to
watch out we got to make sure things
don't get out of hand here
did you hear those russians want to
invade so we're going to send in the
russian peacekeeping forces to make sure
that the people don't invade your
country wait a second so
they're doing that biden is issuing some
sanctions
germany is saber rattling a little bit
about that pipeline that that has become
so central to our political debates over
what russia does the nordstrom 2
pipeline that would cut ukraine out as
the middleman and getting gas to europe
and oil to europe and therefore
vladimir putin now has no reason not to
invade so okay
people are making some moves but all in
all putin's plan is going along just
fine
why is this i actually think that jen
saki gave us the answer as to why
america and the west seem so impotent
right now she gave the answer yesterday
in an unrelated question on an unrelated
podcast she was on rob lowe's podcast
and she explained that what got her back
into politics
was binge watching the west wing
i was working this consulting firm and
the 2012
midterms were starting and i had worked
for former president obama on the
campaign and in the first
term and i kind of was just exhausted as
happens right as a human being yeah and
so i'm working consulting firm and i
start watching the wesling and i don't
know what prompted me to watch it but i
watched i binged you know the entire
thing uh while i was at this consulting
firm and i would do
i'd be working on decks which is like
the worst thing i've ever done in a job
we're kind of editing
i mean it's editing powerpoints
basically yes and i would watch episodes
of the west wing um and it you know in a
crazy way it really brought me back to
come back to politics and i ended up
coming back and doing the 2012
campaign and traveling with then
president obama on his re-election
watching this extremely overrated aaron
sorkin soap opera from the 90s is what
got the press secretary to the president
of the united states back into politics
and she's not the only one she's not i
remember back when i used to work on
campaigns back in school back when i was
with all all the young politicos of all
different stripes
the democrats and exclusively the
democrats
would go on and on about the west wing
oh the west wing oh it's it's inspired a
generation of young politically minded
people
i had no idea what they were talking
about because the west wing is an
extremely liberal show written by an
extremely liberal writer i am so happy
to say
that i have never watched even one
minute of one episode of the west wing i
just never did come on i turned the
channel when i was 10 years old and i
haven't watched it since
but the libs really love that show and
now they're saying that that show is
what got them into politics what
what this phenomenon is called
is hyper reality you might recall
many months ago i had a guy named local
distance on this show
local distance very interesting guy he's
a big fan of this writer charles
baudelaire
uh beaudrier not baudelaire butler is
the guy who says that satan's finest
trick is convincing people that he
doesn't exist beaudriard is the hyper
reality guy and what he means by hyper
reality local distance gave this
analogy is that you start out and you
pick a strawberry off a bush and you eat
the strawberry and you say well i like
that strawberry and then you eat
strawberry jam someone takes a
strawberry condenses it right makes it
the most strawberry e it can be and then
you eat the strawberry jam and then many
centuries later someone comes along and
says wow the strawberry jam so good i'm
gonna make a strawberry candy okay now
you so it's even more that strawberry
the essence of the essence of the
essence of the strawberry and then
someone comes along they eat the
strawberry candy they say you know would
be great i wish i had a strawberry soda
so you take the strawberry candy you
somehow make it even sweeter you get the
strawberry soda then you make maybe a
strawberry slurpee slushy it's even
sweeter than that and then eventually if
you've only grown up on the strawberry
slurpee
if you if you eat an actual strawberry
you'll have no idea what it is
because the strawberry slurpee doesn't
taste like a strawberry tastes like a
strawberry candy it's it's been so
removed this is this is what beautiful
yard would call hyper reality our
politics today is a hyper reality it's a
politics about a fiction about a fiction
about a fiction about a fiction about a
fiction of political reality and that
might help to explain why we in the west
are absolutely having our lunch eaten by
our enemies on the political
scene
you know if you don't want to have your
lunch eaten when we're talking about
your own home your own personal
financing i would strongly recommend you
check out american financing head on
over to american financing today why so
you don't throw money out the window
mortgage rates have been all over the
place lately they are still extremely
competitive you need to take advantage
of them before they are gone it's as
easy as a 10 minute call to american
financing that's america's home for home
loans you can take advantage of a free
mortgage review you can learn about ways
to save up to a thousand dollars
per month that's just money right now
that you're throwing out that you've
given to the bank for no reason
whatsoever
they can help you solve this they're
helping people save that kind of money
right now without starting terms over
you should not pay interest on years
that you don't need instead ask about
custom options they can write any loan
term 10 years and over but only if it
helps you the way to do it right now to
take advantage of this is call 800
685-5696
that number is 800
685-5696 or if you're a millennial like
me you probably go to the web
americanfinancing.net nmls182334
nmlsconsumeraccess.org
it actually matters that jen saki says
that she got into politics because of
the west wing because it explains why
these libs are so bad at politics
particularly forget about the domestic
sphere for a second particularly when
you're looking at the west versus our
enemies
another example of hyper reality would
be bruce jenner
would be transgenderism generally you've
got
now
uh this the simulacrum of a simulacrum
of a simulacrum of a woman
a transvestite a drag a drag queen is
not
an imitation of a woman a drag queen is
an imitation of an obscene caricature of
a woman but you if you look at a drag
queen and a woman you can you can tell
there's a big difference between the two
if you look at a drag queen and a
cartoon of a woman they're they're
closer because it's so far removed
that's where our politics is when
jensaki gives her little sassy press
conferences why don't they work
you know she gets she comes in she's got
that slam on peter ducey and she sounds
super arrogant and condescending and
glib and i find it very off-putting and
a lot of americans find it very
off-putting but she keeps doing it why
because she thinks she's in a sorkin
script she thinks she's in an episode of
the west wing but real life doesn't work
like tv soap operas
okay and so she's going to come out and
she's going to have some big zinger at
vladimir putin
and then we're at minute 19 of the
episode and putin's going to pull the
forces out of donbass right out of
ukraine is that what's going to happen
no no that's what would happen on the tv
show but real life is not
a tv show
it's really sad it is it is a problem
that has been strongly encouraged by our
media that's why there's great news
coming out of the media right now which
is
that kyle rittenhouse
the alleged white supremacist terrorist
worst man in america remember joe biden
called him a white supremacist in his
campaign ad well kyle rittenhouse
who in reality is a teenager who
defended himself against antifa
thugs
who was then exonerated in court carl
rittenhouse is launching something
called the media accountability project
to hold
the
mainstream legacy establishment call it
what you want media to account for their
lies
me and my team have decided to launch
the media accountability project as a
tool to help fundraise and hold the
media accountable for the lies they said
and deal with them in court
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be suing news organizations
that maliciously lie about people who
are in the news
is that the plan
yes sir we're going to be holding them
accountable tucker
do you exp i mean i guess i have to ask
a kind of a dumb question but you know
why isn't there a group like this that
exists already since the media so often
are not observers they're players
they're participants
in the news
why hasn't someone done this before
that's a good question tucker and i'm
not sure to be honest but
i don't want to see anybody else have to
deal with what i went through so i want
to hold them accountable for what they
did to me because i don't want to see
anybody have to go through what i went
through
this is great i really applaud kyle
rittenhouse as a historical matter this
actually has been done before and not a
lot of people remember this but the
people who did it is us we not the daily
wire but the organization that existed
just before the daily wire was kind of
the precursor organization it was called
truth revolt it was i didn't even work
for truth revolt directly i was i was
friends with the guys when they did it
but it was ben and jeremy and drew
actually had this company called truth
revolt and it was not just a media
outlet that would produce videos and
commentary and news articles they would
actively go after media figures who were
spreading lies who were who were pushing
a radical leftist agenda and and they
would they were sort of like immediate
matters for the right and it existed for
a while then it sort of morphed into the
daily wire and the rest is history but
it's really important i'm glad that an
organization like this now exists
written house is absolutely right the
reason is there is no such thing as
freedom of the press in america
there is no free press in america
you we hear the hand ringing and the
pearl clutching and the sorkin watching
liberals they say no freedom of the
press where the journalists are under
attack it's not we don't have freedom of
the press and the reason we don't have
freedom of the press is frankly because
of our press
and because of our technology apparatus
and because of our government
working in tandem with these private
corporations
you want you want an example of this
i'll give you an example this
no one has picked up on this but i saw
it yesterday so there's a story
horrible story about this child molester
who uh he's he was a couple of weeks
before his 18th birthday he attacked and
molested a 10 year old girl he is now 26
years old he's finally being held to
account for his crime but because of
la's extremely leftist district attorney
george soros installed attorney named
george gascon
the guy the 26 year old male child
molester is going to serve his sentence
with a bunch of little girls because
after he got arrested this pervert
decided to start identifying as a woman
and he's laughing about this he's
boasting about this he there was just a
phone call he had with his father where
he laughed that he wasn't going to get a
difficult sentence and now he's
identifying as a woman and because of
gascon's insane policies he won't be
serving his sentence with adults he's
going to be serving with little girls
like his victims hahaha how funny and so
i read a report on this in the f in fox
news
here is what fox wrote in a phone call
tubbs posted that nothing would happen
to her
after she
pleaded guilty
to to democrat district attorney george
gascon's policies and laughed that she
won't have to go back to prison or
register as a sex offender
she also made explicit remarks about the
victim that are unfit to print
hold on what wait she who's she fox news
she
is oh she refers to the male
child molester who attacked this little
girl wait hold on why are you calling
him her why are you referring to someone
who should go by he as she
aren't you fox news aren't you supposed
to you're supposed to at least be the
right wing outlet now you're using the
preferred pronouns of this pervert child
molester who's by the way doesn't even
really think that he's a woman he's just
identifying as a woman to get a lighter
sentence and he's boasting about this
why are you fox news doing it i'm not
just throwing shade at fox news i'm
really not i know exactly why fox news
is doing it
fox news is doing this because they know
that if they refer to this man as an
actual man as he is
that then the fact checking websites and
all of the other leftist organizations
that work with facebook and work with
social media companies and work with
google to determine where your news
articles show up in the algorithm on
social media and in the search engines
they're going to attack fox news and
they're going to rate fox news lower and
then fox is going to get fewer clicks i
have seen it happen anyone who works in
media has seen it happen it's one of the
little-known
facts about the way our media operate
but the if
the media companies even right-wing
media companies don't play ball in some
way with these people their websites
will effectively disappear from the
internet
that's that's freedom of the press for
you this is why by the way when you were
reading the coverage about the crack
pipe policy at the white house just a
week or two ago this is why the coverage
changed really quickly and then all of a
sudden it kind of disappeared from the
news because the fact-checking websites
decided that yeah sure joe biden had
this policy where he was giving out
crack pipes he was giving out safe
smoking kits and safe smoking kits and
harm reduction kits they do generally
speaking include crack pipes it just
makes sense how could it be a smoking
kit if it didn't include something
through which you can smoke and yeah the
department of homeland or of health and
human services didn't deny that the kids
included crack pipes they just said that
in the future they won't and then the
white house came out and they they did
deny it but then they got rid of the
policy anyway okay anyway false ten
thousand pinocchios if you report on joe
biden's crack pipes you're a liar you're
spreading fake news and your articles
aren't gonna show up in the search
engines
then what happened the news articles
disappeared
gaslighting before our very eyes that's
freedom of the press in america you know
freedom of the press in america is when
the new york post gets hunter biden's
laptop speaking of crack pipes and and
discovers that hunter biden has a ton of
shady deals not just a bunch of weird
sex stuff going on all over the world
but a ton of extremely corrupt business
dealings with countries like ukraine by
the way so this is going to be very
crucial to american foreign policy
oh whoopsy daisy you can't share the
news report it's fake news the laptop's
probably hacked or oh it's not hacked
okay well whoopsie daisy whatever
nevermind you can't share it not only
can you not post it you can't even
message it privately to your friends
that's freedom of the press in america
we do not have
freedom of the press in america what
so ever good job mr rittenhouse i hope
you take these dirt bags down the reason
that we need a media accountability
project by the way
is so that we can get to something even
vaguely resembling freedom of the press
in america the reason that we need to
take the new york times down the reason
that we need to take the the arbiters of
what news you're even allowed to read
like big tech down is so that we can
have freedom of the press in america so
great job i hope i hope britain has wins
major journalist awards for defending
the free press because that's exactly
that's exactly what he's doing the left
is getting so aggressive here not only
are they trying to shut us up not only
are they trying to prevent us from
sharing any stories that are critical of
their regime now if you look up at
america's hat our neighbors to the north
they're trying to steal the property of
political
dissidence
now when you want to get property at a
really important property at a really
good price i would strongly recommend
you check out
rockauto.com whatever part you need for
your car or truck go to rockauto.com
right now
in the how did you hear bettisbox write
in knolls so that they know that we sent
you
rockauto.com has been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years the
website is so easy to navigate even i
can do it what i really appreciate about
rock auto other than making it very
simple to shop for auto parts is they
don't have a ton of gimmicks it's not
like you need to log in
tuesday morning at 10 a.m and they're
gonna have a 15 off sale but only until
11 and then or it's not as though it's
it's different prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers no it's very simple
same prices for everyone reliably low
super easy saves you time saves you a
ton of money they have the parts they've
got availability unlike the brick and
mortar store they've got the parts there
for you right now
go to rock rockauto.com
you're going to see a little how did you
hear about this box type in knowles
k-n-w-l-e-s
just to say you appreciate them for
supporting the show because i certainly
appreciate them for supporting the show
and i appreciate you for going over to
rockauto.com you're going to love it
it's going to make it a lot easier to
fix up your car truck head on over
rockauto.com now
the canadians beat the truckers
eventually the truckers lasted a very
long time
but finally justin castro
and the rest of the canadians got the
truckers to go away one way they did it
was they sent in a bunch of cops to beat
up the protesters to take their property
to send them home
now the mayor of ottawa is calling for
keeping all of that property you
remember the
trudeau government invoked the
emergencies act which allowed them
effectively to suspend the rule of law
in canada they could go in they could
stop peaceful assembly they could take
property they could force other people
to use their property to help the
government so now the canadian
government has a lot of these protesters
property their trucks to say nothing of
their other property and the mayor of
ottawa suggests
the government just keep it
this is costing a small fortune for the
taxpayers of ottawa and that's one of
the reasons why under the emergency act
i've asked our solicitor our city
manager how can we keep the
tow trucks and the campers and the vans
and everything else that we've
confiscated and sell those uh pieces of
equipment uh to help recoup some of the
costs that our taxpayers are absorbing
so that's one of the provisions of the
emergency act and we have been a
beneficiary of the emergency act as they
debated on the hill asked the members of
parliament to consider uh it's helped us
a lot on things like confiscating
vehicles not having to swear in peace
officers to the rcmp
and so many other things that have been
very helpful over the course of this
period
so this is just outright theft
i don't i don't think that even
the libs are going to pretend that
there's some grand principle here
anymore if you look at what's going on
in canada it's very simple they
suspended the rule of law they beat up
protesters and they took their stuff
that's what they did
and what are you going to do about it
nothing
because they've got the power and their
ruling and tough luck
what we're seeing now
is a decay of politics
from even the semblance of a principled
logical rational endeavor right down to
the old norm of politics
friend versus enemy
us versus them
blm burns down a bunch of stuff stops up
a bunch of streets causes all sorts of
mayhem
kills people
that's fine that's a mostly peaceful
protest they get to keep their property
they get to keep their freedom no
suspension of the rule of law a bunch of
truckers start honking because they
don't want to take an experimental drug
for a virus that doesn't pose a grave
threat to them
we need to ruin their lives we basically
need to lock them up in gitmo short of
that we're going to take their stuff
throw them in jail beat them up
no mercy for the truckers
blm and antifa terrorists they can do
whatever they want they're wonderful
they're great patriots
truckers waving the canadian flag nope
they got to go they're evil they're
neo-nazis they're the worst people
on earth
there's no principle here
it's just friend versus enemy
it's just old power politics group
interest what are you going to do about
it
what are you going to do about it not
only are people not going to stop the
government from doing this
but even here in america
a lot of people are applauding the
government's actions there's a poll that
just came out this is really spooky from
trafalgar group shows that
while most americans disagree with
justin trudeau's handling of the
canadian freedom convoy
most democrats
support the crackdown
according to the poll 55.3
of of total respondents disapproved
compared to only 35.1 percent who
approved of what trudeau did
but there's a huge partisan divide
65.7 percent of democrats approve
you guys 74 75 percent of independence
disapproved 83 87 rather percent of
republicans disapprove but
65.7 percent of democrats approve
now you might say okay good well that
means that this kind of thing is not
going to come to america this kind of
crackdown this kind of suspension of the
rule of law is not going to come to
america because the majority of
americans disapprove yeah but you're
forgetting something
the political parties are not created
equal the democrats are the ruling
political party the democrats have all
the institutions of power they've got
the media they've got the schools
they've got hollywood they've got big
tech they've got the corporations
they've got the bureaucracy which
is effectively our government most of
the time and they even have the elected
government right now they might not come
november but right now they've got
unified elective government
so they've got all the power yeah maybe
the democrats
have a minority view here on this issue
but because they've got all of the
institutional power if you think that
the freedom convoy crackdown we saw up
in america's hat can't come to america
you've probably been smoking that good
joe biden crack i don't know that you've
probably had your head turned and turned
to mush
because that absolutely can happen here
vladimir putin was talking about the
bolsheviks
during his speech on rewriting the
history of ukraine and he focused a lot
on the bolsheviks because of how
politically effective he said they were
don't forget the bolsheviks were a small
minority they were a small political
minority who completely upended the
political system of russia you do not
need a majority this is an important
lesson of history you do not need a
majority to change the political order
of a country
in fact it is very rare that a majority
will change the political course of a
country it's usually a very small very
energetic minority
particularly one that can can gain
institutional power as we're seeing with
the left right now could it happen here
or could we have a crack down here it's
already happening here okay we've got
the state of the union coming up where
joe biden is gonna i don't know he's
gonna get a few energy shots they're
gonna prop him up like weekend at
bernie's and he's gonna mumble his way
through the state of the union he's
gonna gaslight all of us and tell us no
the the gas isn't very expensive and the
inflation isn't historic and the putin's
not invading other countries and it's
really good it's all good anything bad
is trump's fault but it's really
everything's great so we're preparing
for all of that but we're not going to
be able to get anywhere close to the
capitol because that capital fence is
going right back up
right now the security officials around
the capital will reinstall the fence
that we saw in february march april of
last year because of security concerns
they're worried about they're worried
about you they're worried about the
insurrectionists the terrorists the the
rioters the terrible
january 6th people are going to show
back up right and there's no end to this
there's no end
for the democrats there is always an
insurrection around the corner
very often it's a real insurrection and
it's their own guys called blm and
antifa that doesn't matter they'll
ignore that but but
for the ruling
class of this of this country right now
there's always a grave threat so you got
to put the fences back up you've got to
take away people's rights you've got to
lock them down at least a little bit
you've got to keep them away from the
levers of power it's already
happening here you might call it
putin-esque
you know when when i want to
try to get around all this awful
censorship we're seeing when i want to
try to get around with what's happening
in our political system with the
suppression of dissent one great way to
do it and to get your message out is
constant contact i have used constant
contact for over 10
years i have used constant contact since
really i guess since i was in college
political campaigns non-profits small
businesses it is this phenomenal digital
marketing platform that helps all of
these organizations of all sizes build
grow and succeed with email marketing
they've got contact management they've
got industry-leading list growth tools
social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all from an easy to use platform
they've got a 97 deliverability rate so
you can rest assured that your customers
and your potential customers are getting
the right message every single time the
platform is extremely easy to use i told
you i've been using this since my very
first jobs and what i didn't know
anything about marketing or these
digital tools it's really really simple
anyone can use it they've got thousands
of integrations you can sync constant
contacts tools with the tools you are
already using to start your free digital
marketing trial today head on over to
constantcontact.com
we got a ton of new content coming up at
the daily wire we've got a great new
series on the enemy within that is
coming up with the acclaimed journalist
lee smith the second episode is going to
be going deeper into biden's ties to
chinese business not just joe biden but
his family his crooked brother his
crooked kid
this is a really important documentary
definitely go check it out
actually you can check it out right now
take a listen to this trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
[Music]
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about one person
infiltrating senior levels at the cia or
the white house we're talking about an
entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
get ready for the enemy within it's
terrific go check it out also if you
want to have a cup of coffee with ben
shapiro you can't he doesn't do that
he's a very busy man and he doesn't like
going to large social gatherings all of
the time but
you can be a fly on the wall ben is
sitting down on his new show the search
with his friend the wonderful historian
neil ferguson uh they will be chatting
about all sorts of things in a relaxed
casual environment and you can be there
if you're a daily wire subscriber this
is exclusive to daily wire members so
head on over to dailywear.com subscribe
we will be right back with a lot more
we've got breaking news from white
supremacy you know i think we need to
have our daily white supremacy update so
pervasive is the white supremacy in
america here's the latest from white
supremacy
a professor at suny binghamton
very well known very well respected
state college in new york
this woman anna maria candela
is
giving priority to any student who is
not white in her class she if you're
white she doesn't want to hear from your
stupid privileged cracker mouth keep it
shut she wants to hear from the other
students because of how privileged
the white people are you see her course
social change introduction to sociology
reads this on the syllabus
we practice progressive stacking when
calling on people
participating class discussions i guess
grammar is not her strong suit
she probably means people to participate
okay
progressive stacking i love all of these
lib
slogans like what does that mean it
sounds good i guess it's progressive i
like that you know look it's just
progressive stat what does progressive
stacking mean it means you don't call on
the white kids that's what it means she
says this means
we try to give priority to non-white
folks
to women and to shy and quiet people who
rarely raise their hands it also means
that if you are white male or someone
privileged by the racial and gender
structures of our society to have your
voice easily
voiced and heard have your voice voiced
you get your this woman boy she must
have missed
i know she has a phd probably but it
doesn't sound like she graduated from
the third or fourth grade if you if you
don't get your voice easily voiced and
voiced and voiced and voiced we will
often ask you to hold off on your
questions or comments to give others
priority and we'll come back to you a
bit later or at another time
you know if you're one of those awful
whities who is so privileged that when
you pay to go to a university your
teacher refuses to call on you because
she hates you because of the color of
your skin because of how privileged you
are you know uh you're gonna have to sit
there quietly
while other people talk
you know other people who can't talk and
this kind this is sort of offensive to
black people right
and other non i guess hispanic people
asian people if you're
if you're a woman
if you're a black person if you're shy
and quiet if you don't know how to speak
if you just can't use your mouth you
know it doesn't work you don't know what
your larynx does you don't know how to
use your vocal cords you unlike those
white people who can speak because
they're able to do things but you're not
because of the color of your skin or in
this case your sex or because you're shy
and quiet we're gonna we're gonna have
you speak
what we're seeing here
is exactly the same thing we're seeing
up in canada
it's it's it's the trucker issue
replicated
at the university campus which is the
crystal ball of where your society is
going it's
friend versus enemy what this teacher is
saying is i don't like white people
white people are my enemy i think
they're bad i think they need to be
taken down a few notches i don't want
them to get as good in education as the
other students i guess unless they're
white women
right because she she says that all
women are going to be called on so i
guess the white women it's really just
white men i hate white men
and i don't want them to get a good
education
so i'm going to give much more of my
attention to all the non-white men in
the class
because i like them because they're my
friends and the white men are my enemy
and i hate them
there's no
arguing out of this i mean we we joke
about the illogic of this but it's she
doesn't care this woman's not basing any
of this on logic
it's just it's pretty simple she just
doesn't like white guys okay
and so what's the answer to that the
answer to that is to fire the professor
and make sure she never works in a
college again
it's not even the the university hasn't
even
really slapped her on the wrist when
there was an outcry over this policy
the university gave some blah blah blah
bs boilerplate answer but how other
professors follow the rules and it's
good and they educate people and but
they didn't address the issue directly
well here's the issue this teacher hates
some of her students
on the basis of race and sex i guess and
she should be fired and she shouldn't
work again
need we need some cancer culture folks i
wish i wish we lived in a time when
politics could be
gentlemanly
elevated sophisticated when we could
have much more rational discussions
politics always involves a little bit of
brute force but there are times when
it's much more rational and civilized
than others and we're in one of the
others right now okay
we're in one of the times where there's
very little civility very little reason
in politics and so what we need to do is
just fire these bad people and take them
out of positions of power
the educational
institutions are at the forefront of the
revolution as they have been for 50
years the austin public library in texas
is now not only offering
spring break sex ed camp for free for
little teenagers to teach them about a
bunch of creepy sex stuff
they're actually they're actually paying
the teenagers to go to the sex ed camp
they're going to pay you
to go
learn about lots of weird creepy stuff
why
well
what you hear from from the program is
get paid to learn about sex ed
you'll you'll learn about gender
pronouns gender identity when you sign
up you can say are you male female
transgender
maybe you don't identify this program
the austin healthy adolescent program is
a progressive program
that envisions a generation of liberated
youth and young adults who are valued
participants in achieving health equity
so it's like pro progressive stacking
health equity we're getting a lot of
liberal slogans that don't don't seem to
mean very much right now
this program by the way funded by your
taxpayer dollars funded by the
department of health and human services
this actually
clarified my thoughts on why
comprehensive sex education is so bad
is i don't know i grew up in a pretty
liberal place we had comprehensive sex
ed when i was a kid
wasn't nearly as comprehensive as it is
today we didn't talk about
transgenderism we didn't talk about
lots of the things that are taught in
these classes but it was still you know
fairly
fairly comprehensive
and there wasn't much of an outcry where
i lived because i grew up in a very
liberal place but i remember at the time
there were huge debates over
comprehensive sex education i thought
what's the big deal why are these
conservatives so upset about it
the reason it's a big deal
is because
it's not just about biology
it's not just about science
no education is just about biology and
science when you're teaching something
like sex
you are inevitably also teaching
something about morality
and ethics
and politics
it is it is not possible when you teach
a child what sex is
you must teach them what sex is for
so you can as people used to do say okay
set when a mommy and daddy love each
other very much you know when the birds
and the bees
start to get a little frisky is that how
it happens i don't know
what happens is a husband and a wife
will get together and do this thing and
that's how babies are made
and that teaches you that sex is for
procreation it's for men and women
to get together in an institution called
marriage and then and only then
should they have sex and they should do
so with the openness to life to create a
new generation that's not what sex ed is
today sex said today is that sex is
what you do when you want to feel
pleasure and it doesn't matter if it's a
man and a woman who love each other very
much frankly it doesn't matter if it's a
man a man or a woman a woman who love
each other very much the love that
doesn't that's not a big deal
it can be a man and a woman it can be
two dudes in a goat it can be whatever
kind of arrangement you want that's fine
and you should always use contraception
contraception is really good and really
important and yeah it's true
certain groups like you know the
christians and you know other old-timey
religious groups they don't like
contraception but that's okay we what
we're teaching now is contraception's
really good if you do get pregnant if
you do get that horrible disease called
pregnancy from from sex that's okay you
can have an abortion abortion is good
it's just safe health care there's
nothing wrong with abortion
and if you by the way if you're a man
you think you're a woman that's totally
natural and good and normal and you
should mutilate your body that's what
that's what sex education is it is a
moral education
it's a religious education
it has to be
it that's this is true of all education
but especially when we're talking about
sex something so fundamental to our
human nature
you can't just talk about what the thing
is and divorce that from what the thing
is for
what the thing means what the
significance is
of the act
and this is why they're paying kids to
do it they're paying kids to do it
because they have the state the
political radicals have
a
deep interest in indoctrinating you into
the ruling ideology and it appears it
appears
to be working
they just do it and and
we we can try to say no this is a bad
idea let's defund it but it doesn't
matter because our voices are drowned
out we don't we just don't have a ton of
institutional power
and the smartest thing that the left can
do here
is just ignore us sometimes the left
goes after us and makes a boogeyman out
of us but the smarter move is to ignore
us you're seeing this on cnn right now
so for a long time on cnn during the
reign of jeff zucker and all of the
other creepy sex people who used to run
that network who probably still do but
they kicked out a bunch of them when
they got caught
during jeff zucker's reign
cnn would talk about fox news
all the time
fox news this fox news that
now since zucker left he only left a
couple of weeks ago
f the the mentions the on-air mentions
of fox news have dropped from 100
mentions per week to just 34 mentions
per week so this was obviously a
political decision in the c-suite over
at cnn told the hosts stop publicizing
fox why because they know an important
political rule
do not
publicize your enemy the only thing
worse than being talked about is not
being talked about okay this is the old
conventional wisdom
and
you can see this with donald trump
donald trump was the fringe candidate
everyone made fun trump wasn't going
anywhere right but everyone kept talking
about trump everybody
his enemies couldn't stop talking about
him even his friends couldn't stop
talking about it they talked about trump
and they made memes about trump and he
spread throughout the culture and then
he became president
vladimir putin actually remember
vladimir putin said there's no question
trump is the strongest candidate right
now in the presidential race and people
laughed at putin but putin look he's a
good politician the guy's been in power
for 20 years more than 20 years he knows
good politics when he sees it everyone
was talking about trump
this is what
cnn
has pivoted on they say okay we're not
going to talk about our enemies anymore
all right this pro that's probably why
it's a return to normal politics the
only other strategy
is to
if you have to talk about your opponent
only do so to marginalize them to censor
them to ostracize them that's what
they're doing in canada right now
there's a member of parliament in canada
who's insisting that the phrase honk
honk it's a phrase of support for the
canadian truckers the phrase honk honk
you know it's real it's an acronym right
it's hong kong it's h do you know what
hong kong
really means do you know what the dog
whistle really means
heil hitler is what it means
i like many canadians were shocked to
see nazi flags confederate flags
dismayed and angry and hurt
horribly hurt
so how many nazi flags does it take
how many donors from the capital riots
it's eleven hundred and counting
who have donated to these illegal
blockades
how many guns
need to be seized
how much vitriol
do we have to see of honk honk which is
an acronym for hail hitler do we need to
see by these
protesters on social media
how much
how many
times do we have to see clear indicators
that what is out there
is not about the hard two years that
every canadian has suffered
the indications are so clear
there's so did you honk honk that sort
of rhymes with
mineconf coincidence do you know some of
these truckers in there were videos of
them in their trucks drinking water you
know who else drank water you guessed it
adolf hitler that's who
how much longer
will we tolerate this and not lock them
up in prison and take all their property
and ruin their lives and suspend the
rule of law
because they're nazis you see
is that
is that so
the canadians are using this to great
political effect it worked right they
sent the they sent the truckers away
however if we want to understand what is
actually going on in the political
situation we need to remember
not everything is hitler
not every political moment is the 1930s
in germany not every political opponent
is a nazi
this lack of historical understanding is
why we're getting our lunch eaten right
now by vladimir putin
but furthermore the domestic agenda
that these radicals are pushing
to call their political opponents here
in the states nazis to take away their
property to completely ostracize them to
shut them up to upend the rule of law to
say that the entire founding of these
countries the development of our own
civilization is evil and terrible from
within
that
is probably at a deeper level why we're
having our lunch eaten by our enemies
right now we need unity we need clarity
we need conviction well the left has
spent 50 years destroying all three of
those things in the united states is it
any wonder that our enemies have taken
note i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show